RAE: I'll be very brief. Thanks, Miroslav.
And good to see you all across the globe, there.
Let me start with
a distinction
not very different from thick versus thin
that comes from the psychologist and philosopher William James,
who distinguished
acute
and chronic religion.
Acute religion is
identity-defining
and demands
to subordinate other forms of knowledge
to religious doctrine or dogma.
And chronic religion is
more porous and more--
penetrable
by other ideas.
The thought
I have is that acute religion, combined with certain
external circumstances,
is the most dangerous combination. And those external circumstances
would be poverty;
isolation;
government which is
undemocratic
and authoritarian,
or wholly inept
as in failed states;
illiteracy;
and early stages in the world demographic transition--
that is, stages where you have
disproportionately large numbers of young people
in a population
and low expectations of life span.
If you look at
violence which is not institutionally organized,
the vast majority of it comes from very young men.
and that combination is-- is, I think, particularly dangerous.
I teach in the business school,
and I therefore like to believe that commerce is a good thing.
Voltaire,
centuries ago,
put forward the proposition that
Mohammadens,
Jews
Christians,
and Hindus
who meet in a stock exchange
learn to tolerate one another and learn to have a certain sense of ironic detachment
about their religious differences.
And I think actually the process of globalization
has within it the potential to promote
this more ironic,
chronic
attitude toward
religious
dogma
and i'll stop there.